Buen día precisamente Martín borrego
quien es un alto funcionario de la
cancillería de México recibió en el
aeropuerto Benito Juárez a línea paredes
y a sus hijos hasta el momento lo único
que se ha podido conocer es que el
gobierno del presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador le va a otorgar a una
residencia a la esposa del expresidente
Pedro castillo y también una manutención
mensual cuyo mundo se desconoce hasta el
momento Mientras tanto en Perú han
surgido diversas reacciones de rechazo a
la actual presidenta Dina boluarte por
haber permitido que se le otorguen
salvoconductos a Lila paredes se le
recuerda a la mandataria peruana que en
la fiscalía Investiga Lilia paredes por
presunta corrupción al integrar
supuestamente una red criminal que la
fiscalía señala estaría dirigida por el
ex mandatario Pedro Castillo Mientras
tanto para tratar de tres baños fríos
paños fríos a esta situación la
cancillería peruana ha dicho que el país
Se reserva el derecho de emprender un
pedido de extradición contra línea
paredes cuando la República peruana lo
considere necesario y otra de las
noticias en Perú es que hay un cambio de
gabinete porque Alberto o tal hora es el
nuevo jefe del Consejo de ministros
Francisco Quién es él y Qué desafíos
tiene este nuevo gobierno
es un abogado constitucionalista
constitucionalista él tiene un destacado
prestigio en el sector también es
catedrático y tiene experiencia también
en gestión pública durante la
administración del expresidente ollanta
humala otarola se desempeñó como
ministro de defensa y justamente fue
esta cartera que el 10 de diciembre
último la actual mandataria lo como
ministro de este sector ahora
ASUME la
Les encargo que le ha designado Dina
boluarte y su principal tarea va a ser
tratar de generar confianza consolidar
la unión de los peruanos Y tratar que se
reactive la economía hay que destacar
que diversos expertos han señalado que
la pbi de Perú va a crecer a lo mucho
Dos punto cuatro por ciento este año y
su primer batalla de fuego va a ser
tratar de sentarse a dialogar con los
dirigentes de las protestas para generar
un clima de mayor estabilidad y que
permita que tanto el Perú y los peruanos
sobre todo salgan de este estancamiento
político social y económico en que se
encuentra